dude what is sang oh maybe they're
inside the whole gang oh what's up
gamers we're back in simp Nautica on the
floor
stand up please disgusting I don't even
know why I had this to begin with
get rid of it how do I play the game I
forgot there we go okay listen we're
gonna make that that's we're gonna make
today prawn suit I said prawn suit
nothing else nothing else Keep Calm okay
to make prawn suit you need I don't know
I don't want to go into submarine again
my life's experience in the submarine
has been nothing but failure and wet
pants I don't want to go into submarine
I don't care how beautiful she is I
don't even know why I'm playing like I
basically beaten the game or a watch
that point can you be quiet please
I need this creep line hey guys look at
this floor gang shut up woman you don't
know anything about breathing
oh yeah I was supposed to read the PDAs
oh wow fish go blah blah that's so
interesting
I'm supposed to read this sure shall
read it all right let's make fiber mesh
bling I don't know why I didn't already
have this but now we can go deep and
your mom prawn suit there you are
I need the plasteel ingot Eric girl
uh-huh uh-huh
and I can get a grappling suit prawn
suit grappling arm that's probably not
important I have lead I have diamond and
nominal get glass and nominal anomaly an
AMOLED class how I mean can I even make
an AMOLED class what is an AMOLED class
if you think about it I don't think I
can make a number that class aerogel
okay I can make aerogel an AMOLED glass
okay I can make it it oh wait Plus
stealing it all right let's start with
that you know what I have so much stuff
to get I might as well just take a break
and I'll be back once I've done it okay
it actually didn't take too long I have
everything except aerogel aerogel I
think I know where to find it though so
we're just gonna go I'm not taking the
submarine I'm not not worth it let's see
how far we can go and still find our gel
because that's all I want okay the
answer is we cannot go very far deep
maybe I should get the summary Jesus I
all might stop I think their spawn here
somewhere Jack got it
stupid [ __ ] stinky face here's the
aerogel they spawn in this area because
there's hair everywhere look at that
beautiful okay all right I don't see
anything I don't see anything of value
hair gel
come on I have to okay all right so now
stop it illegal we did that go away all
right
rebreather Thanks oh there's radiation
god damn it god damn it all right it's
fine
everything is against me all right
where's the hair gel hair gels are you
Aaron gel maybe this is our chick that's
hair gel this looks like air gel
all right let's not go there then she
says I don't like this place this is
scary
why are there so much fish in this game
Dimond okay I have a sneaking suspicion
quiet quiet woman quiet I have a sneaky
stinky suspicion that we might have to
go deeper I don't like that stop it
I'm scared of everything shut up air gel
are you a nerd gel hello I know what it
looks like I've seen them down here hey
there's a pot back hello I've been here
Jesus Christ why is someone speaking to
me I have to use the submarine I'm not
happy about this it's so stressful I
can't do this guy's
I can't beat this game I mean I already
beaten it technically but get that the
wait day at least I'm comfortable in
flooring gang I'll say that much I'm
very comfortable thank you for asking
I swear I've seen air gel here could it
could it could it have been no I'm lying
there's no hair gel
only death because I need Ruby I swear
I've seen Ruby somewhere someone
watching me like oh my god shut up
paralyzed aggressive dude good loot
though ok took some damage we're OK
cement son ok alright
worst watch the entrance there it is
beautiful
ok powers back online hope we got decoys
we're fine IKEA sub will rice once more
all right
yes come on quiet shut up alright decoys
ready this is so cool
let me think let me fix one quick thing
that's very important base there it is
IKEA sub number 3 and now we're ready to
head out and it's on yeah yeah I'm not
afraid I'm not afraid at all there's
nothing to fear only fear itself
help me please God shut up make as
little noise as possible
and we'll be okay yeah what did I what
did I just hate this is Captain IKEA
speaking this is Captain PewDiePie of
IKEA sub speak number three speaking we
got a targeting coming on our north west
side they can't they can't kill what is
dead right okay all right that's fine
that's fine us that's nothing
let's turn on the off there okay be
careful here all right you're making
you're making a lot of noise IKEA said
we're just easy breezy easy peasy
squeezy going through this oh yeah oh
this is nice look at that nice music and
everything
I see him I'm from ative no problem
we're going deeper going deep
we're only 140 meters down this is
pathetic wash your tail Roger that
all right Kia sub going deeper sorry I
can't have my son all right this is
beautiful okay look at this all right
we're ascending
this is the cameras all right all right
let's make sure we don't hit our tail
that's what I've been doing in this
whole time for IKEA subs but I can
toggle camera line I can cycle cameras
it's just our tail light hey how you
doing buddy okay cool
all right yeah I know how to watch my
tail now it's something leaking over
there that's fine that's fine that's
fine all right we got something on our
radar that's fine that's fine that's
fine check the camera that's fine
oh my God we're still find it I've never
been this fine I feel fine
I feel absolutely fine we're only 200
meters deep Jesus Christ get out okay we
got enemy land all right that's fine
everything is fine
we're just chillin we're just chillin
hey you better not touch me because I'm
Swedish Swedish people touch you don't
do that you don't do that that's what I
said
Hey oh we got hostile enemy hostile
enemy go away you better not break with
me what Moche going full-speed
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid
yeah because I'm running no no no
there's no way they're gonna attack
twice hold my you hate I hate this aw I
hate that I hate it I got it I got it
fine spike decoy all God is downstairs I
can't see anything
I can't see anything nothing I see I
don't see in the sea all right all right
all right just don't panic - somebody do
we not have lights and boats
turn on lights you stinky brainers your
own fault Felix oh well yeah yeah did
anyone want something I don't think so
we're doing great we're going smooth
we're smooth sailing what's down there
so done with this I hate you all you can
go and suck my heart
suck my lord I'm going there we go in
here and ah peace at last thank you
engines off okay all right sir we're at
230 237 that's not bad this is all to
get frickin air gel I'm flying
we're gonna find I think the mat ends
here I'm pretty sure it does so we're
gonna have to go up again it's too much
there's to it there's too much I need
water as well okay I drop water I can't
I only put one at a time there's only
one at a time
you can do it it bit this submarine
there's navicomp ass how about that
that's great what in that what is that
what is that
where am I am i underneath the giant
ship oh my god seriously how did I end
up here
oh god it's so big I'm scared I'm scared
I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared I'm scared oh my face
I'm sorry I kiss up you don't deserve me
all right I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm
out I'm out I'm out I'm out I want
aerogel I'm out get out of the way get
out of their way
god I have this ther away from I can't
see anything in case you can't see
anything
what's the problem
literally what's the problem Oh Oh God
Oh Oh No I sure brought supplies last
time honestly that was my bad why is
IKEA sub red excuse me
communist like chiesa oh yeah I smell
smell smell
I still have the same color what's going
on oh that's bad it was a bad one dude
this is so creepy I don't like it oh my
god oh my god no is that it
oh that's a rock jeez sighs okay we go
this way now gamers screw the heck yes
I'm I'm sorry I don't mean to say it but
like yeah going deep the voice what yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
did you guys hear something yeah so I
think they spawn on the rocks if I see
anything bigger then my submarine I'm
quitting just super clear so I think I
can use the rebreather here yeah nice
so we can actually stay a little longer
I'm just want to name the Ruby nothing
else that's the nails yes Jess Jess yeah
that's how it's done another one yeah
yeah I got nothing on me fishes got
nothing on me you go no they're on me
all right what's the other thing we need
right jealous sang found in the walls of
caves okay oh we're here is that a is
that a gel sack hey what are you doing
this is expensive yes it's my breathing
hole there's gotta be balls in here
because I sure as hell don't have any
I'm so glad I placed it here that's some
good eye that's some good stuff right
there okay that's a water pipe to suck
on get it I actually remember cuz I got
a bunch of comments saying that I should
explore this island so I might as well
do that while I'm here yeah oh god my
shadow scared me god damn it where's my
gel where's my gel
give me my gel where's my gel where's my
dear Oh a water cave in the cave I go
blub blub I go blub blub I go down and
go blub blub blub blub blub blub blub
blub blub blub blub blub what happened
to the tropical island ice it used to be
so nice really
this guy can't run and keep a flashlight
at the same time this is nice a little
hike guys always down for a hike no
fishes up here
no pictures I said no fishes I were in a
cave gamers this could be good
oh my god it's literally okay the same
flippin game oh my god my stomach scared
me are you kidding me alright alright
alright I'll eat some I'll eat some I'll
eat some ball but like Sebulba I'll eat
some alien flora samples dude diamond
gamers gold gamers lithium what is this
the blip I think I need something here
right ion cube I do have that goddammit
alright we'll come back here then this
must be some added expansion pack stuff
because I already beat in the game so
they must have just like updated for
more content for me thank you developers
I appreciate it alright we're very high
right now not sure what I feel about
this we're going higher oh yeah oh yeah
nothing's gonna stop me oh yeah oh my
god can you flip off dude
come then I just broke my like I hope
you're happy I remember doing this in
Halo just trying to like get above the
map and stuff if you played co-op mode
you can you could launch you can launder
yourself weed grenades and jump on top
of friends and stuff that was so fun
smash like if you can relate I'm just
gonna jump that was smooth dude that was
nice I just wanted some jelly I just
wanted some jelly I just wanted some
channel mate talk to me some slack
please family weirdo beardo Irish boy
playing subnautica I already beaten the
game you know
curl too many fishes 9 out of 10 that
would say oh my god my antics is killing
me dude floor gang it's a rough gang to
be part of but I got a commit dude we
found no capes
we found no balls but we have our we
have our integrity no hey that's my home
right there all right I just have to
build in a radioactive area that just I
just had to do that for some reason all
right we're gonna go down with IKEA sub
maybe is that that that cannot be air
gel I cannot have been looking so long
for that no that is not
you better not be air gel don't punch
okay good you're just a float there you
look disgusting this I will need I had
one all right yeah yeah it's done here
oh yes dad this is a kid it was
underneath us all this time
how about that that's crazy this is as
far as I can go shut shut up shut up
shut shut oh my god oh oh you what's
your what's your problem what's your
problem
stop stop stop stop
gel or sack jealousy suck my dad's right
jealousy
we're just here dropping batteries in
the ocean guys no big deal
someone said they found it in the deep
sparse reef which is located southwest I
hid my cell how is that physically
possible
whew maybe down here okay they have to
be down here
I am so surely oh yeah it's down here
whoa
pretty please meet me or you're jealous
there's gel here there's gel here oh man
oh oh don't eat too deep
are those gel sacks whoa all right let's
put you on and let's go JAL JAL JAL JAL
JAL are you jump not afraid of you not
the faith of shark fish just go blub
blub dude what is sang oh maybe they
inside the hole oh I don't want diamonds
I don't want material goods I don't want
Joel I want gel balls that's all I want
Shadow Ball where are you currently gel
sacks are more rare than nether right
dude what the hell is that oh it's here
this is where the jealous ex are Joe Joe
sec just a sec no no Joe suck
Joe yeah yeah well that's a girl sack
yeah for they said I couldn't find your
sack but I found a sack yeah yeah
alright I go back in there there's a
rubies here too oh my god I go back I go
back we go back with the gel sack
Joe sack now oh now we can make a prawn
suit how long did that take me my amis
is killing me floor gang it's not what I
thought it would be it's a rough life oh
god oh god oh god this is what it's like
to have baby home sweet home I
well-conserved the cooked boomerang nom
nom nom nom Oh delicious
now we can make a hotel oh my god I took
so long
Oh God God so captain grab that and
there we grab two plasteel one NFL of
glass one air of yo I need to Ariela
let's make one more Ariela
luckily this is all I got this is all I
got
alright this is an epic gamer moment
happening right here oh yeah I guess up
you look beautiful my god your where's
your stripes dude IKEA sub more like if
you have this race nothing like making a
giant prawn suit in the middle of the
night on an alien yeah yeah weeks of
trainings meaning
oh whoa whoa whoa again a flop again at
last I could punch people like a brofist
vlogging we are here with blogging with
blogging yes ah yes
we fly now luckily I think we're gonna
go in here
your gang they said I would never be
flawed game they said I couldn't do it
oh we're going deep now gamers oh we're
going deep we gon be alright alright I'm
gonna end that episode that because I'm
sweating and I'm tired smash like four
more Florrie gang please and I see you
guys next time